depuis son décès prématuré à l'âge de 53
ans Jacques Villeret repose au cimetière
de pérusson près de Loches une tombe
simple sans fioriture qu'il partage avec
sa mère non loin de celle de sa
grand-mère sur la stèle ce petit mot
rappelle les rôles qui ont rendu
l'acteur si populaire dans le cœur des
Français 17 ans après sa mort les
visites autour de sa dépouille se sont
pourtant estompés
ces visites ont été extrêmement
nombreuses les premières années puisque
beaucoup de gens venaient demander à la
mairie l'adresse l'endroit exact de la
tombe et effectivement c'est passages
ses visites se sont estompées il y en a
de moins en moins mais il y en a encore
quelques-unes de temps en temps
notamment des vacanciers qui s'arrêtent
à pérusson alors aujourd'hui que
reste-t-il de Jacques Villeret dans la
région qu'il a vu naître et grandir non
loin du cimetière se bat restaurant lui
rend hommage l'antidote fut son dernier
film et puis à Loches il y a ce fameux
trompe l'oeil près de l'Office de
Tourisme une oeuvre
en 2001 sur la façade de l'ancienne
école de garçons un établissement qui la
fréquenté entre 1956 et 1960 un détail
bien connu des Lochois et même des
visiteurs de passage
est-ce que vous pouvez vous retourner
Yannick et me dire qui est à la fenêtre
à côté de l'office de tourisme
pourquoi est-ce qu'il est là Jacques
Villeray
de la région il a été à l'école sur
loches et peut-être même l'école de
musique parce que vous pourriez me citer
les un ou deux films de lui
le dîner de cons
et
pourtant j'en ai vu quelques-uns
parmi la verdure un buste représentant
Jacques Villeret toujours en place c'est
là enfant qu'il venait se promener et
jouer avec sa sœur